Мерія ісландської столиці Рейк’явіка.
Всередині майже нікого: на календарі п’ятниця,
а в мерії запровадили скорочений - 36-годинний робочий тиждень.
Із минулого року працівникам дозволили працювати на 4 або 5 годин у тиждень менше.
Робити це можна гнучко.
Колеги з маленькими дітьми охоче щодня йдуть з роботи на 45 хвилин раніше.
Усі інші скорочують робочий день у п’ятницю.
Саме тому по п’ятницях офіс уже о 12-ій зазвичай майже порожній.
Менше роботи - за ту ж зарплату.
Чи таке можливо, в Ісландії з’ясовували не один рік.
Дослідження проводили, передусім, у державному секторі та в сфері
охорони здоров’я. Результати тепер оприлюднили,
привернувши увагу всього світу.
Дані дослідження свідчать, що за меншої кількості робочого часу
люди здатні виконувати той самий обсяг робіт, що й раніше.
Вивільнений час вони проводять із родиною
й друзями або займаються спортом.
Учасники, як показало дослідження, менше страждали від стресу
або професійного вигорання. Окрім того, вони рідше хворіли й брали лікарняні,
а це заощаджувало гроші як компаніям, так і державі.
Схожий експеримент у Японії ще яскравіше продемонстрував переваги
4-денного робочого тижня: там продуктивність працівників у тестовий період
підстрибнула на 40%! Тож у країні, де перепрацювання вважається нормою,
скорочення робочих годин хочуть затвердити офіційно.
Нещодавно японський уряд оприлюднив рекомендації компаніям -
поступово переходити на 4-денний робочий тиждень.
Чиновники хочуть убити двох зайців - надати японцям більше особистого часу
й, можливо, вирішити демографічну проблему,
та спонукати до підвищення кваліфікації працівників.
Широкого схвалення, утім, ідея поки не отримала:
і компанії, і співробітники побоюються,
що за втрачений день доведеться платити.
Зі схожою пропозицією - менше працювати - виступив і уряд Нової Зеландії.
Там, окрім задоволення особистих потреб громадян,
воліють будь-що підживити постраждалу від пандемії економіку,
й зокрема - туристичну галузь. Ось тільки деталі плану поки невідомі.
Я дійсно закликаю подумати про це, якщо ви роботодавець
і можете це зробити. Подумайте про те, чи може спрацювати
щось подібне у вашій компанії,
тому що це дійсно допомогло би туризму по всій країні.
Уряд Іспанії пішов ще далі -
компаніям, які перейдуть на 4-денний робочий тиждень пропонують фінансову підтримку.
Проєкт розраховано на три роки, його мета - підвищення ефективності праці.
Обсяг, утім, доволі скромний: лише 50 мільйонів євро.
Схожу ініціативу - менше й ефективніше працювати - обговорюють у Фінлядії,
Швеції, Великобританії. Утім, є одне "але".
Експерти сумніваються, що покращення можна запровадити
для усіх професійних груп. Більшість сходяться на тому, що скорочений тиждень
може стати привілеєм лише "білих комірців".
У Німеччині ідею менше працювати ще до пандемії підтримувала
щонайменше половина громадян.
При цьому експериментували з робочим часом лише одиниці підприємств.
Здебільшого технологічні компанії, які й раніше дозволяли співробітникам
працювати віддалено або за гнучким графіком.
Запитань до ефективності на подібних підприємствах не виникає
завдяки сучасним методам управління проєктами - як-от "скрам" або "аджайл".
Утім, досягнути подібної гнучкості у менше технологілозованих
галузях хоча й складніше, теж можливо, вважають у Німеччині.
На заваді інша велика проблема німецького ринку праці - нестача персоналу.
Там, де уже бракує працівників, ще скоротити їхній робочий час без утрати продуктивності -
важко, пояснюють у Берліні. Враховують політики
й національну рису німців - консерватизм і прагматичність.
Є й інше обмеження для 4-денного тижня -
фінансове становище працівників. Хоча у Німеччині 55% опитаних
воліли би менше працювати, навіть якщо їхні доходи скоротяться,
решта виступає проти такого варіанту.
Так само і в Ісландії: висока вартість життя змушує частину людей
працювати одразу на двох роботах.
Удень я працюю теслею, а по вечорах – у нічному клубі.
Так що я працюю всі дні тижня.
У мерії Рейк’явіка тим часом більше не хочуть повернення до 40-годинного
робочого тижня. Працівники пишаються тим, що змогли
самостійно перелаштуватись на коротший робочий час.
Ми розуміємо, що мусимо виконати ту ж роботу
за коротший час. Це означає, що ми мусимо по-іншому організуватися.
Тепер у нас коротші наради, але ми до них краще готуємось.
Ісландія на законодавчому рівні закріпила 36-годинний робочий тиждень.
Це перший крок. Довгострокова мета - 4-денний тиждень.
А до того часу для більшості працівників мерії Рейк’явіка
вихідні починаються з 12 дня п’ятниці.